et 33 mille 400 décès l'europe reste
très fortement impacté par l'épidémie
avec plus d'un million de cas et près de
cent mille morts l'espagne enregistrent
185 mille cas et plus de 19000 300 décès
en italie l'épidémie est à l'origine de
169 milka et plus de 22 mille décès hier
en france 1723 personnes sont passées
aux urgences pour une suspicion
d'infection kobe 19 c 8 % de l'activité
totale d urgence à la suite de la prise
en charge aux urgences 38% et personnes
ont été hospitalisées cette proportion
augmente régulièrement avec l'âge des
personnes et 4 pour cent ont dû être
transféré en réanimation hier 491
intervention de sos médecins ont été
réalisés pour une suspicion de kovy de
19 c 10 % de l'activité totale des
associations sos médecins sur le
territoire
les passages aux urgences pour suspicion
de kobe 19 et les appels à sos médecins
pour le même motif sont stables au
niveau national et dans toutes les
régions
ce soir nous avons des informations de
1279 établissements de santé qui font
état de 31000 190 personnes
encore hospitalisé pour une infection
par qu'ovide 19 le nombre de malades
hospitalisés reste donc très important
en 24 heures ce sont deux mille cent
soixante sept nouveaux malades qui sont
entrés à l'hôpital c'est un peu plus
qu'hier mais pour le troisième jour
consécutif
nous observons une baisse mais elle
reste extrêmement légère grâce aux
sorties nous avons 115 personnes
hospitalisées pour kobe 19 en moins par
rapport à hier
nos efforts collectifs montrent leur
efficacité
ce n'est qu'en respectant très
strictement les gestes barrière toute la
journée et partout le confinement strict
et la distanciation physique d'un mètre
ainsi que la distanciation sociale c'est
à dire la réduction des contacts que
nous y parviendrons tous ensemble 6027
patients dans un état grave
nécessite des soins lourds en
réanimation un tiers de ces patients ont
moins de 60 ans nous comptons 80 18
patients âgés de moins de 30 ans est
pris en charge en réanimation au cours
des dernières 24 heures
243 nouveaux malades ont été admis en
réanimation pour une infection
kovy 19 le solde reste négatif et c'est
une bonne nouvelle depuis neuf jours
aujourd'hui il y à 221 patients en moins
c'est une baisse des besoins en
réanimation qui se confirme mais je vous
le rappelle nous sommes à un niveau
exceptionnel de besoin de réanimation
puisque nous avons six mille patients
qui sont infectés par le cos vide et qui
sont en réanimation en france alors que
la france avait il ya quelques semaines
5000 lits de réanimation au total il
faut noter donc qu'il existe encore des
tensions dans certaines régions 68 % des
patients hospitalisés en réanimation ont
des problèmes de santé pré existants et
5 pour 55% d'entre eux ont plus de 65
ans
en ce qui concerne les outre mer
guadeloupe guyane réunion martinique
mayotte recense des hospitalisations 121
une hospitalisation actuellement et 47
en réanimation au total et c'est un
point important depuis le début de
l'épidémie
trente quatre mille quatre cent vingt
personnes qui étaient hospitalisés sont
rentrés à domicile c'est important ce
sont des bonnes nouvelles c'est 1608
personnes qui sont rentrées à domicile
dans la seule journée d'hier
et je ne parle pas évidemment des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui ne
passe pas par l'hôpital et qui
guérissent spontanément mais vous l'avez
noté avec le nombre d'hospitalisations
2167 sur les 24 heures avec le nombre de
besoins de réanimation 243 nouveaux
patients la circulation du virus demeure
à un niveau élevé
nous surveillons de très près tous
ensemble la situation de nos aînés dans
les établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux
au total depuis le début de l'épidémie
nous avons 58 1989 cas d'infection à
qu'ovide se confirmer ou possible vingt
mille deux cent soixante douze de ces
cas sont confirmés par test pcr
il s'agit des remontées de 5473
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
principalement des ehpad d'ailleurs qui
participent à cette remontée
d'informations très importante au niveau
national et je tiens à le redire
l'essentiel des cas l'essentiel des
malades observé l'ont été au cours des
semaines 12 13 et 14
c'est à dire à la deuxième moitié du
mois de mars en ce qui concerne la
mortalité
vous savez que nous surveillons la
mortalité survenus à l'hôpital
la mortalité survenu en ehpad ainsi que
la mortalité survenu en ville grâce à la
mortalité totale qui nous est signalée
par l'insee en ce qui concerne la
mortalité hospitalière 11460 18 décès
sont à déplorer depuis le 1er mars et
dont 4 118 décès de plus qui hier 80 2%
des personnes décédées ont plus de 70
ans et 20 décès sont survenus outre-mer
nous déplorons 7203 décès survenus en
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
et rattaché au covit 19 depuis le début
de l'épidémie le 1er mars
l'essentiel des décès est observée en
ehpad
au total depuis le 1er mars en
additionnant les décès observés remis
hospitaliers les décès survenus en
institution nous déplorons 18600 81
décès en france en lien avec cette
pandémie de kobe 19
vous le savez aussi nous avons saisi
l'insee qui nous propose est donné très
récente actualisée de ce qu'on appelle
les décès toutes causes confondues
il ne s'agit donc pas seulement des
décès liés à l'infection coville 19 nous
aurons ces données
de mortalité attribuable à la maladie
mais seulement après étude de tous les
certificats de décès ces données qui
nous sont fournies quasiment en temps
réel nous permettent de pouvoir comparer
les décès semaine après semaine sur les
différentes années et la france
surveille les aider c'est depuis des
décennies ainsi nous pouvons parler
d'une mortalité attendue et nous pouvons
parler d'une surmortalité lorsque le
nombre de cas est supérieure à la
moyenne attendue toutes causes
confondues par rapport à l'année
dernière mais surtout par rapport à
toutes les années qui ont déjà fait
l'objet d'observations
je rappelle que les le nombre de décès
varie en france d'année en année et de
mois en mois mais en moyenne c'est
important de le rappeler il y a un peu
plus de 1600 morts par jour en france un
peu plus de onze mille sept cents morts
par semaine et donc les mois varie entre
40000 et 60 mille décès chaque mois
selon les évènements selon qu'il ya un
épisode de grand froid un épisode de
canicule où une épidémie de grippe donc
il ya des grandes variations de mois en
mois en france et de semaines en
semaines mais donc même si la part
attribuable aux co vide n'est pas encore
connue nous pouvons observer si les
semaines que nous recueillons sont
normales ou en excès ou en déficit
éventuel par rapport à l'attendu nous
avons une hausse de la mortalité
nationale depuis la mi mars
elle a commencé progressivement en
semaine 12 avec 16% d'augmentation s'est
renforcé en semaine 13 avec 35 %
d'augmentation
puis en semaine 14 la semaine 14 c'est
la dernière semaine de mars
du 30 mars au 5 avril avec un excès
totalement exceptionnel de 59,6 %
d'augmentation
et cet excès continue à s'observer mais
en europe on est peut-être encore un
tout petit peu tôt sur la semaine 15 qui
est la semaine du 6 au 12 avril où nous
avons déjà un excellent nationale 2 37%
donc vous le voyez l'impact de
l'épidémie
l'impact probable de l'épidémie
il se traduit par un excès de mortalité
depuis la mi mars jusqu'à début avril
on observe aussi cet excès au niveau
régional notamment sur la semaine du 6
au 12 avril avec un excès qui est
observé dans cette région
l'ile-de-france grand test bourgogne
franche comté au de france auvergne
rhône alpes centre val de loire et
normandie
enfin pour la même semaine du 6 au 12
avril à l'échelon des départements 37
départements présentent un excès de
mortalité dont déjà 5 dont un niveau
exceptionnel paris hauts-de-seine
seine-saint-denis val-de-marne et val
d'oise sont donc des départements
franciliens les 37 départements dont je
vous parle sont dans les régions île de
france cran test bourgogne franche comté
au de france auvergne rhône-alpes
normandie et centre val de loire on
retrouve régulièrement ce grand quart
nord-est plus concernés par l'épidémie
par la diffusion virale que d'autres
régions de france nous avons enfin la
certification électronique des décès il
ya en france de nombreuses communes qui
ont des certificats électroniques de
décès à ce jour nous avons déjà 6688
certificat électronique de décès qui
mentionne une infection par qu'ovide 19
dans les causes médicales de décès
depuis le 1er mars ses 27% de l'ensemble
de ces certificats électroniques et de
ces décès certifiés et donc nous aurons
des moyens ainsi d'étudier les causes de
mortalité de façon encore plus rapide
un point important qui nous est signalée
par l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé et que nous observons évidemment
avec beaucoup d'attention c'est l'impact
du 2 litres de l'épisode épidémique sur
les comportements des français par
rapport à leur propre santé
nous avons observé une forte diminution
de l'activité aux urgences pour toutes
les classes d'âge de l'ordre de 48 %
pour le nombre de passages de 21% pour
le nombre d'hospitalisations après
passage aux urgences et en particulier
sur les semaines 12 à 15
donc là des semaines que je vous ai cité
de mi mars à début avril et qui est
vraiment très nette par rapport aux
semaines précédentes hausses et en
particulier aux semaines équivalente
de 2019 du printemps 2010 9 donc nous
avons évalué cet impact pour trois
groupes de pathologie cardio neuro
vasculaire qui peuvent d'ailleurs
présenté des urgences vitales et qui
nécessitent une prise en charge
immédiate sur cette période de quatre
semaines le nombre de passages aux
urgences et d'hospitalisations pour
cardiopathie ischémique sadir atteintes
cardiaques notamment infarctus a diminué
d'environ 35% pour ce qui est des
pathologies neuro cardio vasculaires les
accidents vasculaires cérébraux
c'est une baisse de 27% et pour les
maladies veineuses et thromboemboliques
les phlébites les embolies pulmonaires
c'est là aussi une réduction importante
de 28% et de 18% pour les
hospitalisations par rapport à la même
année 2010 neuf donc
heureusement depuis la semaine 14 et la
semaine 15 nous observons une nouvelle
hausse de ces pathologies
ce qui est un bon signe ça veut dire que
les patients reprennent confiance dans
leurs établissements de santé et c'est
ce que nous disons tous les soirs il
faut quand on a une pathologie chronique
mais aussi quand on a une pathologie
aiguë ne pas hésiter à appeler son
médecin traitant a appelé le service qui
vous suit puisque vous avez et si
éventuellement une pathologie chronique
ou à appeler le 15
si l'on naît en dépend d'urgence vitale
donc on voit de nouveau une hausse des
cardiopathies ischémiques les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux ou des maladies
veineuses thromboemboliques désormais à
l'hôpital nous souhaitons encourager ce
mouvement car il ya aussi des personnes
qui sont malades d'autres causes que le
coc vie de 19
il est donc absolument indispensable de
poursuivre la bonne prise en charge de
sa pathologie
parce que c'est vraiment important pour
votre santé donc n'hésitez pas à appeler
votre médecin traitant a appelé le
service hospitalier qui vous suit ou en
cas d'urgence vitale à appeler le 15 le
15 n'est pas du tout saturé en ce moment
et donc il est évidemment là pour
répondre aux urgences vitales
je le dis aussi j'invite mes collègues
médecins généralistes médecins
spécialistes médecins hospitaliers à
appeler pour prendre des nouvelles de
leurs patients les plus fragiles et à
leur proposer des rendez-vous et les
bilans dont ils ont besoin cet ensemble
toutes et tous que nous vaincrons cette
pandémie et tous ses effets
nous revoilà relâchons absolument pas ce
soir nos efforts
vous le voyez le confinement commence à
porter ses fruits
il y a moins de patients hospitalisés il
ya moins de patients admis en
réanimation c'est une baisse lente mais
régulière
nous devons donc poursuivre nos efforts
dans le confinement limiter encore jour
après jour tous les contacts appliquer
plus que jamais les gestes barrière la
distanciation physique d'au moins un
mètre et la distanciation social avec
une réduction donc régulière et
quotidienne de tous nos contacts je vous
remercie de question pour le généraliste
la dgs va-t-elle établir un critère
épidémiologique permettant d'établir le
déconfinement comme possible le 11 mai
un critère sur le nombre de nouveaux cas
de co vite par jour où le nombre de
nouvelles hospitalisations ou un autre
critère alors évidemment nous serions de
très près la situation épidémiologique
vous l'avez noté nous surveillons en
particulier l'activité de ville
l'activité des médecins généralistes
activités de sos médecins qui nous
traduit finalement la circulation du
virus au sein de la population nous
surveillons évidemment pour protéger
notre système de santé hospitaliers nos
équipes soignantes et surtout les
services de réanimation
le nombre de malades hospitalisés le
nombre de nouveaux malades qui arrivent
à l'hôpital et le nombre de nouveaux
malades qui arrivent en réanimation
donc tout ça est évidemment des critères
d'observation des critères évidemment
très importante pour préparer notre
système de santé à la sortie du
déconfinement qui est prévu par le
président république le 11 mai et nous
allons aussi évidemment nous être très
attentif à l'activité de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé pour permettre à
toutes les régions de se préparer dans
les meilleures conditions
à cette étape importante pour tous les
français et après le déconfinement en
cas de deuxième vague quels seront les
critères qui vous alerte auront le
doublement de nouveaux camps 24 à
l'augmentation du nombre
d'hospitalisations dans quelles
proportions
alors je vais peut-être vous dire
quelque chose qui va vous surprendre
mais la première vague
elle a été très fortement atténués par
tous les français il faut qu'ils en
soient conscients leur part
fait respect du confinement leur
apprentissage des gestes barrières le
respect des mesures de distanciation
physique et social nous ont permis
d'éviter beaucoup de morts et d'éviter
beaucoup de drames humains et
d'admission réanimation c'est vraiment
important qu'ils se rendent compte que
nous avons fortement casser cette
épidémie qui était au départ très
contagieuse avec un virus qui se
transmettait à un très grand nombre de
personnes on voit bien aujourd'hui la
réduction du rythme de l'épidémie la
réduction de la vitesse de l'épidémie
elle est liée aux efforts des français
et donc le message il est un peu étrange
c'est que après le déconfinement les
français auront aussi cette
responsabilité de freiner tout risque de
diffusion virale
il y aura encore du virus en europe on
en est quasiment sûr il y aura encore
des cas mais le comportement des
françaises et des français
après le 11 mai sera le moteur ou non de
l'épidémie et donc ça c'est voilà mais
on a on a un pouvoir très important tous
ensemble qui est d'éviter éventuellement
cette deuxième vague parce que notre
comportement arts a profondément changé
une question pour hospimedia l'espoir
d'une immunité collective sans vaccin
selouane t-il en raison de la montée des
doutes sur la pérennité des anticorps
développés face au virus
je crois que les doutes sur la pérennité
des anticorps ce sont des débats
scientifiques il y a quand même
aujourd'hui des très bons résultats qui
sont que les malades qui ont été malades
avec des tests virologiques positives
qui ont été hospitalisés qui ont été en
réanimation pour l'essentiel vraiment
bac grand grande majorité ont des
anticorps et donc après on peut toujours
se poser la question de quel type
d'anticorps est-ce qu'ils vont persister
mais par définition on n'en sait rien
puisque ces anticorps sont récents les
malades les plus anciens ont trois mois
quatre mois de deux observations donc je
pense que il faut rester solide quand on
a des anticorps c'est quand même plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
et donc il ne faut probablement pas
spécialement rentrer dans ce débat qui
était vraiment un débat de scientifiques
et aujourd'hui il ya objectivement des
personnes malades qui ont été malades
avec un test positif de recherche du
virus et qui ont aujourd'hui des
anticorps de question pour le point la
première question sur les tests
sérologiques les équipes de l'institut
de référence qui vérifie ces tests ont
elles été renforcées y at il une
coopération européenne pour se partager
tâche oui alors c'est un travail
évidemment très important que de
préparer l'arrivée des tests
sérologiques je vous rappelle qu'ils
sont non pas là pour diagnostiquer la
maladie mais bien pour des moustiques et
la présence d'anticorps
il y a plusieurs acteurs qui sont
intervenus la haute autorité de santé
pour définir le cahier des charges de
l'agencé nationale de sécurité du
médicament qui va vérifier une certain
nombre de critères de qualité notamment
la certification des tests et puis
effectivement nous avons un centre
national de référence avec deux sites à
paris et à lyon qui va étudier par
rapport à des techniques de pointe de
référence la qualité des tests c'est à
dire la capacité d'un test à détecter
les anticorps et la capacité d'un test à
détecter des personnes non malades aussi
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle la
sensibilité et la spécificité pour
éviter des faux négatifs
alors là on est parent n'est pas un test
sensible c'est un test qui n'arrive pas
à savoir que vous êtes avec des
anticorps et inversement ne pas vous
donner des faux positifs
c'est à dire vous dire que vous avez des
anticorps alors que ce n'est pas le cas
donc que là encore cette qualité du test
doit être testée et nous avons
évidemment des échanges internationaux
sur ses résultats quand il ya des bons
résultats qui sont validées par un pays
européen
on ne recommence pas tous les tests
inversement quand il ya une alerte d'un
pays qui nous dit que telle ou telle
thèse n'est pas fiable
on ne recommence pas non plus tous les
tests si il ya un consensus
international pour éliminer ce test donc
là il ya beaucoup de collaborations
internationales sur ce sujet madame
geneviève chaîne a déclaré mercredi que
cette commande et 18 marchés pour des
masques avait été passé depuis las
premières saisines ministériel du 30
janvier
pourriez-vous préciser la ventilation
des commandes combien de commandes en
france et pour combien de masques
combien de commandes à l'étranger auprès
de combien d'entreprises et pour combien
de masques alors je pense que je ne
pourrais pas vous donner l'ensemble des
réponses parce que ce serait beaucoup
trop long parce que nous avons mobilisé
tous nos efforts évidemment pour avoir
des masques en grand nombre pour nos
professionnels de santé pour les
établissements hospitaliers et pour nos
professionnels de santé de ville il y a
deux sources majeures de masquer une
production nationale qui a été fortement
mobilisés et qui produit de plus en plus
de masse chaque semaine masques
chirurgicaux et masques ffp2 et des
importations massives de
qui ont été adressées à de très nombreux
fabricants et qui sont actuellement
rapporté sur le territoire français par
des ponts aériens et donc ce sont deux
très importantes quelle quantité qui
arrive désormais jour après jour semaine
après semaine sur le territoire
l'objectif étant actuellement de l'est
de les livrer rapidement au groupe
hospitalier de territoire aux
établissements de santé aux ehpad et aux
officines pour distribution aux
professionnels de santé et donc on voit
aujourd'hui arriver de plus en plus deux
millions de masques et de dizaines de
millions de masses qui sont destinées en
priorité et en urgence aux
professionnels de santé de questions
pour france inter concernant le
dépistage massif dans les ehpad pouvez
vous nous dire combien d'établissements
ont jusqu'ici entièrement été testée
résidents et soignants quelles sont les
consignes que doivent appliquer les
établissements suite à ce dépistage
notamment pour les résidents testés
négatifs peuvent ils sortir de
l'isolément leur chambre par exemple
alors c'est une question qui évidemment
très prioritaire pour nous c'est une
priorité qui a été donnée à la fois par
le président république le premier
ministre et ministre des solidarités de
la santé puisque ce sont les personnes
les plus fragiles auquel les français
sont évidemment très attachés que sont
nos aînés vous savez qu'il ya eu des
mesures de protection des ehpad
confinement bien sûr confinement en
chambre il y a aujourd'hui une attention
toute particulière pour tester les ehpad
à la fois pour les personnels et pour
les résidents
il ya des régions qui ont déjà très bien
avancé dans ce dépistage ile de france
s'est fortement engagée la nouvelle
aquitaine aussi on a beaucoup de retours
très intéressant de de participation
active des ehpad et de tests qui sont
réalisés dans des bonnes conditions
ensuite ça apporte quoi ça apporte des
données importantes pour le personnel de
savoir si oui ou non ils allaient
personnel positif
c'est important de savoir et surtout
pour les résidents et donc l'intérêt
pour l'organisation de l'ehpad c'est
justement de pouvoir se structurer en
fonction des résultats du personnel et
en fonction des résultats des résidents
entre des secteurs atteint par le cos
vide et secteur non atteints par le cos
vite justement pour éviter la diffusion
du virus au sein des personnels au sein
des résidents et entre personnels et
résidents
combien de soignants été infectées
depuis le début de la crise attend des
chiffres fiables alors sur les soignants
en général il n'y a pas de chiffres
fiables mais évidemment l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé qui sont
notamment dans un lit
ce monde santé oms un service de
médecine du travail qui les suit donc il
ya une déclaration qui est fait et c'est
important que nous ayons ces données
n'ont pas peut-être au niveau national
mais au niveau de l'employeur pour
pouvoir assurer le suivi de maladies
professionnelles de ces professionnels
de questions pour diaspora news magazine
est ce qu'un animal domestique et ils
transmettent locaux vides 19
alors c'est un sujet qui est qui est
actuellement étudiée par les
vétérinaires nous verrons ce qu'il en
est en général c'est plutôt dû à la
transmission manuportée c'est le cas
notamment des bactéries c'est à dire que
ce sont les hommes qui contaminent leurs
animaux de compagnie qui seront
contamine ci ne se lave pas les mains
mais c'est pas du portage en tout cas il
n'y a pas de signal aujourd'hui pour
rassurer nos concitoyens sur une
transmission avérée par nos animaux de
compagnie à quand la généralisation du
tests virologiques ou pcr ducobu 19
alors nous y travaillons vous savez que
le président a été très clair
évidemment toutes les priorités qui ont
déjà été définies testé en particulier
les personnes hospitalisées tester les
personnels symptomatique tester les
ehpad vont être poursuivis et puis le
président nous a fixé un objectif
ambitieux c'est de pouvoir tester sur
tout le territoire en france dès le 11
mai parce que les conditions auront
changé toute personne présentant des
symptômes
c'est d'ailleurs très logique puisque
partout moment on lève un certain nombre
de mesures
il faut être en capacité de détecter
rapidement un cas de pouvoir lui
proposer une démarche particulière
d'isolement de pouvoir l'aider aussi a
contacté toutes les personnes avec
lesquelles il est en contact étroit dans
les jours précédents donc tous ces
enjeux de tests rapides d'isolement du
cas de repérage des cas contactez de
démarche particulière de 14 n par
exemple tout ça doit être mis en place
sur tout le territoire national
une question pour france 24 comment
expliquez-vous que l'allemagne qui
compte 15 millions d'habitants de plus
que la france déplore un nombre beaucoup
plus limité de victimes
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'explication
particulière d'abord parce que vous
savez que l'allemagne n'a pas le même
niveau de diffusion du virus et
d'ailleurs vous pourrez noter qu' il n'y
a ni hétérogénéité européenne qu'on
n'explique pas encore aujourd'hui si
vous anxieux on prend un tout petit peu
de recul des pays sont très touché la
belgique par exemple est beaucoup plus
touchée que la france la grande bretagne
et au site forte
m'ont touché et donc là encore les
explications viendront la diffusion du
virus n'est pas la même
les les habitudes ne sont pas les mêmes
les personnes ne sont pas non plus avec
les mêmes pathologies le même les mêmes
tranches d'âge dans tout ça sera étudiée
et nous aurons à l'issue de cette
épidémie a comparé effectivement
l'impact de cette épidémie et
éventuellement les mesures qui ont été
prises mais je ne suis pas sûr que lier
aujourd'hui des moyens de comparer ces
deux pays
3 questions pour la paix m la doctrine
nationale de dépistage en ehpad
va-t-elle évoluer
va-t-on tester systématiquement tous les
résidents et personnel dès l'apparition
des premiers cas comme c'est le cas
actuellement dans certaines régions
alors nous nous faisons en sorte que ça
évolue et jusque c'est ce que je vous
précise maintenant peut-être ce soir il
y a eu des périodes où effectivement
nous nous avions des difficultés danse
pour certains ehpad qui ne connaissait
pas la conduite à tenir
ne savait pas quelle est l hôpital de
référence qui ne savaient pas comment
procéder pour obtenir des tests nous
avons maintenant une organisation
régionale départementale qui est
beaucoup plus fine l'objectif étant que
chaque ehpad qui est confirmée qui est
confronté à une suspicion de cas
connaissent la démarche puisse appeler
l'hôpital s'il ya besoin
d'hospitalisation puisse appeler au
niveau départemental le laboratoire où
les laboratoires qui sont en capacité de
faire les tests
ce n'est pas aux résidents de se
déplacer ce n'est pas au personnel de se
déplacer l'idée effectivement que ce
soit une équipe mobile de laboratoire
qui puisse venir faire le prélèvement en
ehpad prélever toutes les personnes qui
en ont besoin
s'il ya une organisation à mettre en
place entre un secteur kovy d'un secteur
donc au vide on peut être amené à tester
l'ensemble du personnel l'ensemble des
résidents tout ça est lié à la à la
décision du 2 du directeur
d'établissement et c'est important de
pouvoir l'aider à s'organiser dans la
lutte contre l'épidémie
mais aujourd'hui c'est important que les
français réalisent que ce prélèvement et
se fait par un coton tige au niveau du
nez et donc ensuite le coton tige est
mis dans un petit tube de deux cultures
un petit tube de transport est ce le
tube qui bouge c'est le tube qui est
transporté ce n'est pas le patient le
malade ou le résident et c'est ça qui
est important c'est c'est un enjeu
vraiment de simplicime de simplification
de la vie des ehpad qui sont déjà
pleinement mobilisé dans les personnels
sont pleinement
lisez et pour lequel nous voulons
vraiment faciliter la vie et apporter le
maximum de moyens
projeté l'équipe mobile étant à
disposition de l'ehpad pour éviter de
mobiliser encore davantage l'énergie des
forces de l'équipe de l'ehpad qui est
déjà totalement engagée pour protéger
ses résidents gilead a publié des
résultats encourageants sur le rem des
civières dans le kobe 19 les données
publiées à ce stade pour est-elle
justifiée en changement des stratégies
thérapeutiques
alors ce sont des résultats très
préliminaire je crois que ce ne sont pas
des résultats publiés en europe
nous avons leur md et vire aussi en
france dans différents bras ça fait
partie des hypothèses antiviral comme je
les dis qu'il y avait aussi des
hypothèses antirétroviral des anti
inflammatoires des immunomodulateurs et
donc au fur et à mesure que nous aurons
ces résultats préliminaires soient les
comités scientifiques jugeront qu'il y a
un impact tellement positif qu'il faut
arrêter les c'est parce que c'est dans
l'intérêt des malades qu' on puisse
mettre à disposition ses médicaments ce
n'est pas le cas à ma connaissance ce
soir
mais pour tous les résultats
intermédiaires des essais thérapeutiques
soit il y a un effet avéré et à ce
moment là il ya une question qui se pose
c'est l'accès direct à ce médicament
soit il ya une tendance intéressante et
nous regardons de très près ces
résultats parce que là encore il faut
une puissance statistique pour pouvoir
affirmer le bénéfice et le risque de
chaque traitement c'est le cas pour
toutes les molécules qui font l'objet
actuellement d'études vous savez que la
france est un des pays les plus engagés
dans la recherche clinique il ya une
trentaine d'essais qui sont en cours il
ya évidemment toutes les molécules dont
on entend les françaises et les français
entendent parler qui sont testés
actuellement et c'est ça le plus
important c'est que les malades puissent
bénéficier des ces thérapeutiques et que
les françaises et les français est très
rapidement accès à ses informations pour
savoir si oui ou non il ya des molécules
qui ont un impact positif dans la prise
en charge de la maladie
pourquoi ne pas être transparent sur la
mortalité en réanimation la volonté de
ne pas inquiéter la population ne
pourrait-elle pas être assimilée de
l'opacité
alors je pense qu'on est totalement
transparent puisque le point
épidémiologique de santé publique france
est en ligne et donc sur le point
qui est parquée publier toutes les
semaines il y a les statistiques de
réanimation et donc c'est exactement ce
que je veux ce que j'ai indiqué à chaque
fois c'est à dire que nous avons des
grandes variations de mortalité en
fonction de l'âge
en fonction de la présence ou non de
facteurs de risque et en fonction
la gravité du tableau clinique donc si
vous allez sur le site de santé publique
france vous pouvez noter que le le taux
de mortalité observée en réanimation
augmente avec l'âge que le taux de
mortalité de réanimation augmente avec
la présence ou non d'une pathologie
grave initial pathologies cardiaques
pathologies pulmonaires obésité morbide
par exemple et que le taux de mortalité
varie aussi en fonction de la gravité de
votre état en entrant réanimation selon
que vous avez un syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë ou pas selon que
cette détresse respiratoire aiguë est
mineur modérées et sévères et donc pour
vous donner déjà des premiers résultats
la mortalité le taux de mortalité n'est
pas de 50% comme je les lui dans
certains dans certains documents mais
mais plutôt de 10%
donc c'est déjà beaucoup mais ce ne sont
pas les 50% qui sont parfois cité et la
variation de la mortalité observée selon
ce cette étude de santé publique france
elle va de 5 % sur les formes les plus
bénignes mais parce que l'on peut
difficilement parler de forme bénigne en
réanimation les formes les plus
favorables à 20% environ selon que là
effectivement l'état est beaucoup plus
préoccupant n'envoyer que ce sont des
données de donner toujours très délicate
pour des réanimateurs parce que
l'animateur disent toujours que donnait
un taux brut de mortalité n'a pas de
sens puisque évidemment tout dépend
beaucoup de l'état du patient et donc ça
inquiète la famille de savoir que le
niveau moyen est de temps puisque en
fait tout dépend de sa situation de son
âge de son état de santé physiologique
de la présence ou non d'une pathologie
et surtout de l'état initial du patient
lorsqu'il arrive en réanimation mais ces
données sont publiées de questions pour
prévention santé
pouvez vous nous préciser que les cas
que vous présenter chaque soir comme des
cas confirmés sont bien en fait des
extrapolations c'est à dire des
estimations et non pas 100 % de cas à
tester biologiquement
alors effectivement c'est un c'est une
approximation qui est fournie par son
public france comme d'ailleurs à peu
près tous les coups les grands instituts
puisqu'il y a à la fois des données qui
viennent de sources hospitalières avec
en particulier l'activité d'admission et
les aînés et les laboratoires
hospitaliers et il ya des données qui
viennent aussi des laboratoires de vie
là la difficulté que vous pouvez
imaginer c'est que healy a énormément de
tests qui sont faits en france
et heureusement est de plus en plus il
ya aussi des gens qui seront testés
plusieurs fois il ya aussi des gens qui
se font tester plusieurs fois pour la
même pathologie je vous donne un exemple
très simple quand vous êtes hospitalisé
en réanimation vous êtes un plus dans un
essai thérapeutique
vous allez tester potentiellement en
ville parce que votre médecin est
inquiet puis aux urgences pour confirmer
que vous êtes bien atteints d'infections
draco vidé puis vous allez arriver en
réanimation est en rémission on va
surveiller votre votre charge virale à
plusieurs reprises surtout si vous êtes
dans un essai thérapeutique et donc pour
un même patient on peut avoir trois
quatre ou cinq tests positifs et donc la
difficulté pour les personnes qui
surveillent les tests c'est est ce que
c'est un nouveau tas est ce que c'est un
nouveau test positive
un nouveau cas où est ce que c'est
encore un test de surveillance d'une
personne qui a un deux trois ou quatre
tests nécessaires à sa prise en charge
et donc il ya une approximation qui est
fait par son public france qui
effectivement peut surprendre mais c'est
la démarche statistique épidémiologique
qui nous donne une idée du nombre de
nouveaux cas confirmés en france donc
c'est bien ce que je dis selon son type
santé publique france il y aurait
environ 110 mille cas confirmés par pcr
en france mais effectivement c'est un
croisement des données hospitalières et
des données des laboratoires de ville
pouvez vous nous donner le nombre exact
de cas positifs au co vide en france
réellement testé avec un test biologique
alors justement avec la difficulté que
je vous expliquais le ce nombre est
difficilement évaluable mais on s'est
quand même beaucoup de choses en
particulier le nombre de personnes qui
ont eu des tests en ville le nombre de
personnes qui ont été admises à
l'hôpital et ne savait que nous avons
désormais dépassé les 75 mille personnes
hospitalisées depuis le début d'épidémie
et puis nous aurons lorsque justement
nous aurons réussi à éviter tous ces
doublons parce que je vous dis bien que
vous pouvez être testé plusieurs fois de
suite pour le même malade et donc si on
compte directement le nombre de tests
positifs on peut avoir cinq tests
positifs pour la même personne
donc ça fausserait les résultats on
arrivera je pense d'ici quelques jours
avoir ce décompte précis en ayant
l'ensemble des tests réalisés en france
et surtout en est on est incapable
d'éliminer ces tests itératif ces tests
répétés pour le même malades en
particulier en milieu hospitalier de
questions pour libération la dg
constate-t-elle une sur mentalité
spécifiques dans les ehpad du groupe
korian
non je n'ai d'abord je n'ai pas le
propriétaire de l'établissement quand
quand l'établissement déclare n'ya pas
d'ailleurs de raison d'imaginer qu'il y
ait un groupe plus touché qu'un autre
vous avez par contre noté c'est
important peut-être que les français
s'en rendent compte que la disparité
régionale est très importante on voit
bien que l'activité que je vous ai
décrites l'activité de vie de l'activité
hospitalière
elle suit un gradient très très fort
avec une grand quart nord-est de la
france qui est beaucoup plus touchée que
les autres régions
c'est la même chose malheureusement
c'est la même situation pour les ehpad
si on prend les ehpad du grand tu es si
on prend les états d'ile-de-france à
elles sont beaucoup plus touchées par
exemple que les ehpad de nouvelles
aquitaine mais ce n'est pas lié à la
politique de l'établissement ni à la à
l'appartenance à un groupe particulier
mais malheureusement à des différences
de circulation virale selon les régions
pourquoi avoir finalement décidé de
mettre en place un dispositif de
remontées de cas d'infection chez les
soignants
alors nous n'avons pas mis en place 10
pts spécifique d'infection chez les
soignants mais bien du fait de
dispositif spécifique de ce rien des
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
dans lesquels nous testons à la fois les
résidents et les personnels nous avons
des données pour les personnels et ces
données sont d'ailleurs rendus publics
dans le point épidémiologique de santé
publique france une question pour
bloomberg
pourquoi y at il eu une hausse plus
importante de cas dans les ehpad hier
peut-on attendre une telle hausse sur
les prochains jours alors d'abord vous
savez que c'est un travail considérable
que l'on demande d'établissement c'est
une demande de leur part et c'est très
important que les françaises et les
français puissent avoir des accès aux
données de cas confirmés dans les ehpad
je pense que c'est un effort
considérable que d'autres pays ne font
pas donc c'est important de le souligner
nous avons un dispositif de surveillance
des cas confirmés des cas possibles des
décès survenus dans les établissements
c'est très important que nous ayons ces
données après il peut y avoir des
variations importantes en fonction des
jours selon le système de déclaration
dont la note est par exemple après les
trois jours du long week end
donc il peut y avoir des à coups de
déclarations c'est c'est le
l'inconvénient d'un dispositif de
déclaration de ce type mais nous
n'attendons pas particulièrement
d'augmentation de la mortalité si ce
n'est et je le rappelle pour eux pour
tout le monde que il ya d'abord des
formes bénignes puis des formes sévères
puis des admissions hospitalières et le
décès survient souvent après un combat
mené par l'ensemble des soignants et les
soignants se bat pour sauver des gens et
donc les décès malheureusement quand ils
surviennent il se viennent souvent de
façon décalée par rapport à la halle à
aupic entre guillemets ou au plateau de
l'épidémie dont qu'on peut avoir encore
des décès bien après le l'augmentation
maximale des cas observés de questions
pour mehdi site combien de médecins qui
combattent le kobe 19 sont décédés
depuis le début de la crise je n'ai pas
ce décompte
le kobe 19 laisse de nombreuses
séquelles aux malades leur convalescence
pourrait-elle durer plusieurs semaines
quelles mesures prises pour leur suivi
alors il peut y avoir des convalescences
longue il peut aussi ne pas y avoir du
tout de séquelles je pense qu'il faut
aussi rassurer les français
il ya quand même une très grande
majorité des formes qui sont bénignes
avec des formes aux airelles
essentiellement avec des angines fébrile
des maux de tête des douleurs
musculaires
donc on n'est pas sur des formes sévères
parfois avec les formes sévères c'est ce
que je décris parfois pour la
réanimation
lorsque votre poumon a été très abîmée
lorsque votre coeur a établi mais on
peut avoir des difficultés pendant des
semaines qui nécessite une réadaptation
cardiaque une réadaptation ou une
rééducation respiratoire et c'est dans
ce plan ses indications là qu'il ya un
séjour hospitalier l'on a personne sort
fort heureusement de réanimation mais
elle se retrouve dans un service
spécialisé de soins de suite de
réadaptation où elle a des soins adaptés
à ces entre guillemets séquelles qui
d'ailleurs souvent disparaissent mais à
ces difficultés cardiaques ou
respiratoires par exemple ou tout
simplement à ces difficultés motrices
parce qu'il faut aussi rappeler que
quand on passe deux semaines trois
semaines quatre semaines à l'hôpital
s'en sortir de son lit la reprise de la
marche peut être difficile c'était la
dernière question jean merci beaucoup